Raye training scenes our showdown
between bb-8 and bb9
ii a crazy POG moment and po and finn in
canto bite are just some of the many
deleted scenes from Star Wars the last
Jedi yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan
here and today I'm revealing and
explaining a stack of cutscenes and
rejected concepts from episode 8
although the last Jedi is the longest
movie and the Star Wars saga so far
director Rian Johnson has confirmed
there's at least half an hour of deleted
scenes and even more unused footage and
he's promised there will be plenty of
extra scenes on the blu-ray just before
I get into that I'm starting a second
round of my Star Wars giveaway
to enter make sure you're a subscriber
and leave me a comment with your
thoughts about the deleted scenes and
announce the winner of the first round
later in the video oh and if this is
your first time on my channel I do
regular deleted scenes videos movie
breakdowns Easter eggs theories and
giveaways quick spoiler warning I'll be
discussing scenes from the last Jedi in
detail so take care if you've not
watched it yet let's start on act 2
where Rian Johnson's confirmed there was
a huge scene cut which showed rey
performing a type of additional trial
and then a very emotional scene between
ray and Luke afterwards now if you
remember Luke tol Rey he'd teach her
three lessons but in the movie we only
saw her complete two of those before she
decided to leave the island to try and
turn kylo Ren to the light side which
makes me think that this third lesson
was going to be the trial or test that
was cut from the movie there's some
incredible artwork in the art of the
last Jedi book which shows Rey facing
off against two figures or visions which
resemble Darth Vader and obi-wan Kenobi
the fact that race standing in water
here suggests it could be an alternate
version of the mirror scene in the movie
with Luke having tol Rey to enter the
islands cave just as Yoda told Luke to
enter the dockside cave on Dagobah in
the Empire Strikes Back and other
concept art also seems to indicate that
the cave might have explored the duality
of the light and the dark side in
addition to Ray's parentage as it did in
the movie other possibilities for Rey's
deleted training scene include footage
in the trailer and behind-the-scenes
reel of her running with a lightsaber on
the beach concept art of the scene shows
that Rey was running towards the
caretaker village where you can see some
fires
and in another piece of concept art Raya
Lucca on a cliff where they spot
Marauders approaching the village which
makes me think maybe the village was
attacked and Rhea attempted a rescue
alternately the fires in the village
might be from a scene that looks like a
caretaker celebration which means that
Ray's Beach run could be showing her
training while the islands inhabitants
are enjoying themselves concept art also
indicates there could have been a scene
of rape practicing her skills with
numerous training remotes which could
have been a lot of fun to see an old
training remote popped up in the force
awakens when Finn picked it up on the
Millennium Falcon and seeing Rey in a
scene like this could have been a nice
callback to Episode four when Luke
briefly used one to train with obi-wan
Kenobi there's also a separate deleted
and extended sequence with Rey and the
caretakers the art of the last Jedi book
reveals that one particular caretaker
the matron has a problem with Rey being
on the island as Rey is intruding in
this private world and in this private
relationship they have with Luke there
was a little allusion to this deleted
scene in the film when Rey mentioned to
Luke that she didn't think the
caretakers liked her and there's a load
more unused concept art featured in the
art of book some of my favorites include
Luke and Rey on a skiff on their way to
the old Jedi Temple which in this
version was carved into the side of the
island another cool shot and Rey
accessing the temple via a cliff and in
this version of the Jedi Temple the
entrance was specifically designed to
resemble the window behind the Emperor's
throne in Return of the Jedi the idea
being to show that the early symbols of
the Jedi have been used by both the
light and the dark sides after finn
wakes up towards the start of the film
there's a deleted scene where he finds
out what happened while he was
unconscious
basically bb-8 plays a hologram of Ray's
scene in the force awakens where she
kisses Finn on the forehead and says
we'll see each other again it's
interesting this was deleted because in
the last Jedi Finn had a brief romantic
moment with rose after she saves him on
crate and later in the Millennium Falcon
you can see rey looking at Finn while he
takes care of rose
bb-8 also had another deleted scene
where he squirts his evil counterpart b
b9e creature effects creative supervisor
Neal Scanlan told aw that the last Jedi
would feature a lovely moment between
bb-8 and BB
9e which would tell a sort of parallel
story of Vader and Luke we did get that
pretty insane moment of bb-8
commandeering a first order Walker on
the supremacy and some scenes of bb-8
and BB 90 together did appear in a last
Jedi themed ad for Verizon but it was a
shame we didn't get a showdown between
these two droids in the actual movie the
story on can't abide changed
significantly numerous times during the
last Jedi's development initially that
part of the movie was going to feature
Finn and Poe Dameron rather than Finn
and Rose T comb when Rian Johnson
reviewed his early script though he
discovered that Finn and Poe story in
the wealthy casino city wasn't exciting
enough because was no conflict between
the two characters as in some ways they
were too alike so Poe was replaced with
ROS who challenges Finn and therefore
allows his character to develop during
the course of the film
interestingly in early drafts Finn was
also going to be part of the resistance
fighter squadron in the opening battle
in fact he was going to be on the same
ship as roses sister page and actually
witness her death
however Rian Johnson pulled the plug on
this part of Finn's story when he
realized it including a big scene where
Finn had to reveal this to Rose would
slow the movie down even after the story
settled on Rose and Finn in Kanto bite
there were still several more changes to
that part of the movie originally after
arriving in the city the pair were going
to break into a shop to steal a gown in
a tuxedo so they blend in better in the
casino additionally for Rose putting on
the gown was going to be a kind of
transformation moment from her practical
resistence overalls and the tuxedo clad
Finn was going to enjoy getting lots of
attention in the casino until he
discovered he put on his tux back to
front after this scene was deleted Finn
and roses lack of disguise meant they
were easy to spot and apprehend so they
never got to meet the master codebreaker
Brian Johnson also had an important
storyline planned for the master code
breaker which sadly we didn't get to
sing in a deleted subplot Finn and Rose
would have made contact with him after
he finished playing the piano and
singing with a female alien on stage and
the casinos cabaret room after talking
with him they would have learned that he
was on the trail of an insectoid warlord
called the butcher of bricks the
codebreaker plan to stay
the jewels that paid for the warlords
brutal regime but along with rosin Finn
he would have ended up caught by the
Kanto bytes police on the casino rooftop
trying to break into the Warlord's room
and there's more deleted scenes for Finn
and ROS when they get onboard smoke
supremacy to find the hyperspace tracker
mind onsen toll Collider there's an
extended sequence of Finn rows and DJ
sneaking through the mega Star Destroyer
until they arrive at a big office area
and then have to fake out some
stormtroopers which sounds to me like it
could be a hat tip to Hana Luke in a new
hope there's also some concept art which
hints at some of the moments and visual
jokes we might have seen in this
sequence in one of them Finn and Rose
come across masses of lint in a tunnel
which they follow along till they fall
through a trap door into a huge tumble
dryer in the first order laundry room
this scene sounds as if it could have
been reminiscent to the trash compacter
scene in Episode four and was probably
also a joke at Finn after you threw
phasma into a trash compactor in the
force awakens another piece of concept
art then has rose and Finn facing off
against what they think is a bunch of
stormtroopers in a moment evocative of
Han Solo in a new hope but in this case
the stormtroopers are actually revealed
to be just empty suits on a dry-cleaning
rack we did get that funny moment in the
movie with the first-order laundry and
iron droid gag which felt like a nod to
the 1978 Star Wars parody hardware wars
and I think these deleted scenes would
have formed part of that moment concept
art also depicts unused scenes of Finn
and Rose running down a power converter
hallway on the supremecy after that
discovered the pair were going to end up
in a classic Star Wars looking scene on
a narrow bridge with an enormous chasm
beneath in the end though the scene was
rejected as Rian Johnson considered it
too on-the-nose there's still much for
us to learn about Snoke which I'm hoping
will be answered in episode 9 but there
was a small deleted moment with the
supreme leader in the last Jedi in the
cutscene Snoke would have delivered a
line about his gold slippers which I
imagine would have fit in with what the
visual dictionary says that he worsened
because his physical frailties cause
them to prioritize comfort back on the
Jedi Temple island those little pork
critters initially
had some rather freaky multicolored
designs and if you thought that seen
with Chewie and a roasted pork was a bit
dark there's actually a piece of concept
art of a poor being impaled by a
lightsaber it looks like this would have
occurred during the scene when the
little creatures were playing with
Luke's abandoned lightsaber I doubt
though as much chance this would have
ended up in the movie but if it had it
would have foreshadowed the way that
kylo Ren took out one of smokes
praetorian guard with a lightsaber right
through the head by the way if you're
wondering whether any Leia scenes were
deleted Rian Johnson has only said that
no major scenes with Carrie Fisher were
cut however there were some smaller
moments that didn't quite work in the
final movie and actually I talked about
how layers deleted scenes could be used
to complete her arc in Episode nine in
my Carrie Fisher video which you can tap
in the top right to watch or click the
link in the video description below now
what did you think about these deleted
scenes and other any which have been
included in the movie let me know what
you think in the comments below and be
sure to subscribe to enter the second
round of my Star Wars giveaway the
winner of the first round of the
giveaway is on the screen right now so
if that's you send me a private message
with your details and I'll get your
prize out to you I really appreciate all
your support and if you enjoyed this
video don't forget to hit the thumbs up
button turn on notifications and check
out some more videos you're sure to like
right here thanks for watching and see
you next time you became movie lovers